on this vote the yeas are 403 the nays
are 16 2/3 being in the affirmative the
rules are suspended the bill is passed
and without objection the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table today
Democrats and Republicans come together
to demonstrate the strong smart
leadership that has sorely been lacking
from the White House as the House passes
past this tough targeted sanctions bill
to hold the Turks accountable for the
attacks their attacks on our Kurdish
partners the only winners from the
president's disastrous decision in Syria
are Isis the Syrian government Iran and
Russia with these targeted strong
sanctions America is holding accountable
top Turkish officials responsible for
human rights abuses including attacking
our Kurdish partners we are penalizing
Turkish financial institutions who
perpetuate president Erdogan's
corruption and abuses and are preventing
the sale of arms for turkey to Turkey
for use in Syria as the House passes
this legislation we can call upon the
President to support the Kurdish
communities and work to ensure that the
Turkish military acts with restraint and
we require the Trump administration to
finally present a clear strategy to
defeat Isis to vote to support the
sacrifice of our military and our allies
in a vote to restore strength strategy
and sanity to our national security
policy I think that a very strong
bipartisan support to the one we had on
House Joint Resolution 77 will send a
very clear message that we can come
together and we will come together in
the interest of our national security
and the interest of Americans values
which are part of our strengths and
again to fight terrorism wherever it
exists
so that it does not reach our shores
with that general ad from California
yields back the gentleman from New York
reserves the chair now recognizes
you